- Grande corvée de rénovation
au Camp Papillon qui relance
ses activités après un arrêt
forcé par la COVID l'an passé.
SUZIE GUÉRIN, directrice
générale, Fondation Papillon
- L'an passé c'était totalement
déchirant. C'était vraiment
difficile. Cette année, on
repart les activités, donc on
est vraiment plus dans l'espoir.
- En ce samedi,
75 professionnels de la
construction retapent
le camp, bénévolement.
CHRISTIAN ARBOUR, Les
entreprises Christian Arbour
- Tous mes employés,
mes soustraitants, tout le
personnel, l'équipement;
tout est gratuit. On fait tout
ça... Je vais dire comme on dit
: on fait ça sur le bras.
- Merci, merci, merci!
(applaudissements)
- Ils le font pour eux.
Ces enfants et ces familles
pour qui le camp Papillon est
le rayon de soleil de l'année.
Est-ce que tu t'étais ennuyée
l'an dernier de pas avoir de
Camp Papillon?
- Oui.
- Oui, hein?
- Camille fréquente le camp
depuis 14 ans. Le seul lieu
où elle se sent entièrement
acceptée, telle qu'elle est.
VALÉRIE LAROUCHE,
mère de Camille
- C'est un peu pour nous
et pour elle sa normalité.
Tu sais, Camille n'est pas
invitée à jouer chez des amis.
Elle n'a pas vraiment d'amis
à elle, mais ici elle retrouve
sa gang de chums, tu sais,
elle retrouve ses amis
qui lui ressemblent,
qui ont hâte de la voir.
- Sa mère est soulagée
d'avoir obtenu une place.
C'est qu'avec les consignes
de la santé publique, impossible
d'occuper les dortoirs à 100 %.
Le nombre de campeurs
doit diminuer.
- C'est vrai qu'on dit à 20
familles "bienvenue" et on
réouvre le Camp Papillon.
C'est aussi vrai qu'on doit dire
"désolé" à 80 autres familles.
Donc c'est certain que c'est pas
plaisant et on est conscients
du besoin.
- Les autres camps québécois
qui accueuillent des enfants
avec des besoins particuliers
doivent aussi réduire
le nombre de jeunes.
- Très content de revenir
parmi le camp.
- Nathan et ses parents sont
soulagés par la réouverture.
STÉPHANIE RENAUD BEAUDIN,
mère de Nathan
- Effectivement, ça donne
une semaine de répit où est-ce
que, ces semaines-là, on peut
relaxer, faire autre chose.
NATHAN RENAUD BEAUDIN
- Ça leur fait beaucoup
de bien, ça leur permet
de se reposer et pour moi aussi
d'ailleurs.
- Mais lui aussi va apprécier
cette petite pause de ses
parents, entre autres,
pour faire du ski nautique.
ÉMY-ROSE JÉRÔME
- C'est le meilleur moment.
- De l'année au complet?
- Oui.
- Émy-Rose apprécie bien sûr
la tyrolienne.
Et elle aussi le fait d'être
plus autonome pendant une
semaine.
MARC JÉRÔME,
père d'Émy-Rose
- Bien on vient la reconduire,
puis après on s'en va.
Elle est bien contente
de nous voir partir.
- Et toutes les familles
souhaitent revenir en 2022,
alors que les camps devraient